اعلن رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريشيسوناك عن
استثمارات دفاعيه بقيمه خمسه مليارات جنيه
استرليني لمواجهه تحديات عالم متقلب ومعقد
وفق بيان صادر عن مكتبه واقل البيان ان
الحكومه ستقدم المبلغ لوزاره الدفاع على
مدى العامين المقبلين للمساعده في تجديد
مخزون الذخيره الحيويه وتحديث المؤسسه
النوويه وغيرها
واضاف ان المملكه ستعلن تحديثا للمراجعه
المتكامله للسياسات الدفاعيه وان هذا
التحديث سيوضح نهج بريطانيا في التعامل مع
الصين ومع ما وصفه بتحدي العصر الذي
يمثلها الحزب الشيوعي الصيني يشار الى ان
بريطانيا زادت عام 2020 الانفاق الدفاعي
24 مليار جنيه استرليني على مدى اربع
سنوات وهي اكبر زياده مستدامه منذ الحرب
البارده
للمزيد معنى من لندن مراسل الجزيره محمد
المدهون لوضعنا في التفاصيل بشان ما اعلنه
رئيس الوزراء
نعم حسن خمسه مليارات جنيه استرليني هو
مبلغ كبير من المال بالنظر للوضع
الاقتصادي الراهن في المملكه المتحده
الركود التضخمي وازمه غلاء المعيشه غير
المسبوقه منذ عقود لكنه مبلغ اقل بقليل من
ما يطالب او اقل
بمقدار النصف حقيقه مما يطالب به وزير
الدفاع بن ولس منذ ان شنت روسيا حربها على
اوكرانيا وهو يطالب بعشره مليارات جنيه
استرليني لزياده القدرات الدفاعيه الخمسه
مليارات هذه يقول بعض النواب من حزب
المحافظين الحاكم وكذلك من حزب العمال
انها اخبار ستستقبل بكثير من الغبطه في
موسكو وبجين لكن المبدا واضح المبدا الذي
يريد ان يؤسس عليه عمله رئيس الوزراء
البريطانيه ريشونيك وهو الان موجود في
ساندييجو في كاليفورنيا لاجراء مباحثات مع
الرئيس الامريكي والرئيس الوزراء
الاسترالي هو مبدا ان هناك استثمارات
دفاعيه اضافيه لان العالم بات اكثر
تنافسيه واكثر تقلبا وهناك حاجه لتمويل
دفاعيا اضافيه حتى تكون المملكه المتحده
قادره على مواجهه كل هذه التحديات الجديده
ايضا نحن بانتظار تحديث للمراجعه
المتكامله للامن والدفاع والتنميه
والسياسه الخارجيه وهي مساحات عمل تدرك
الحكومه البريطانيه انها متشابكه ومترابطه
والمراجعه المتكامله الاخيره كانت قد صدرت
قبل عامين بالضبط في اذار مارس من عام
2021 لكن كثيرا من التغيرات حدثت خلال
هذين العامين ابرز هذه التغيرات طبعا هي
الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا وهناك حاجه
لتحديث هذه المراجعه تحديدا فيما يتعلق
بالصين الصين التي يصفها البيان الصادر عن
مكتب الرئيس الوزراء بانها تحدي العصر
كانت وصفت قبل عامين بانها منافس منهجي
وكانت توصف قبل عشره بانها في عصر ذهبي من
التعاون مع المملكه المتحده التعاون
التجاري انذاك لاحظ هذا الاختلاف الكبير
خلال عشره اعوام في التعامل مع الصين ومع
الحزب الشيوعي الصيني الحاكم تحاول
المملكه المتحده ان توائم لغتها مع اللغه
الامريكيه المستخدمه اتجاه الصين وتؤكد
انها ستبقى مساهما رئيسيا في الامن الاورو
اطلسي في حلف شمال الاطلسي وقد اطلع
بالفعل رئيس الوزراء الامين العام للنيتو
على هذه التغييرات الجديده في المراجعه
المتكامله وايضا تسعى لحضور اكبر في منطقه
المحيطين الهندي والهادئ وهذا ما تقوم به
من خلال تشكيل التحالفات الجديده تحالف
اوكوس مثلا الدفاعي مع استراليا والولايات
المتحده وكذلك اتفاقيه الوصول المتبادل مع
اليابان
شكرا جزيلا لكم محمد
المدهون حدثنا من لندن